SARA ROBINSON: Welcome back to
our mini series on the What-If
Tool.
I'm Sara, a developer
advocate on Cloud AI platform.
In the last video,
James and I showed you
how to initialize
the What-If Tool, how
to run it on various
platforms, and gave an overview
of each of the three tabs.
Today, we'll be diving into
the Datapoint editor tab,
using the same model has
the last video, which
predicts whether or not a house
is worth more than $160,000.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES WEXLER: When you
initialize the What-If Tool
you're brought right into
the Datapoint editor tab.
This plots all of our test
data along with the model's
prediction for each data point.
For the data points
towards the top,
our model is at
pretty high confidence
that the house is
worth $160,000.
For the data points
towards the bottom,
it has high confidence
that the house
is worth less than $160,000.
Our model is less
confident on the data
points towards the middle.
Let's see what happens when
we click on an individual data
point.
SARA ROBINSON: Here we
can see all the feature
values for this data point.
We can also change
any of the values
to see how this affects
our model's prediction.
Looks like doing this changed
the model's prediction
significantly, which
you can see here.
JAMES WEXLER: The next
capability we'll look at
is partial dependence plots.
With a data point
selected, we can
see how different features
contribute to the model's
prediction for this data point,
or for all the data points
in our data set.
These are calculated by
having the model predict
using the selected data
point while changing
the value of only
one feature at a time
and plotting the results.
The dot in this graph is the
data point we've selected.
And the line
indicates the effect
this feature has on our model.
For example, it
looks like the later
the house was built
the more likely
it is to be priced higher.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Houses with
unfinished garages are
likely to be priced
lower by our model.
And houses with a fireplace
are likely to be priced higher.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: There's
even more you can
do with the Datapoint editor.
If we go back and
select a data point
and click Show
nearest counterfactual
we can see the data point
that had features most similar
to the initial
one we've selected
but with the
opposite prediction.
In the editor panel on
the left, the What-If Tool
highlights the difference
between these two data points
in green and bold.
So we can see what might have
caused the opposite prediction.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES WEXLER: We can
also make all sorts
of custom visualizations
of our data points
making use of any of
the features of the data
points or the model results.
Here we've created a histogram
showing the distribution
of houses by square feet,
with the points colored
by the model's predictions.
As you can see, on
average, larger houses
tend to be more often classified
as over $160,000 by our model.
We can also use the same
data point similarity
used for showing the
nearest counterfactuals,
a measure for custom charts.
Here we've selected a data
point we're interested in
and organized all data
points along the x-axis
by their similarity
to this selected one.
This way we can
easily explore how
the model forms on
the set of data points
that are most similar to
the one we're interested in.
SARA ROBINSON: As
you can see, there's
a lot of tools you can use
for inspecting your model just
within the Datapoint editor.
In the next video, we'll be
diving into the Performance
and Fairness tab.
For more info on what
we've covered here,
take a look at the links
in the video description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]